i gotta ask though because you came to
japan like at a
obviously much earlier than us because
for us coming to japan you know there's
plenty of resources for us to like learn
about what japan life is like you know
we have like a lot of
way more vloggers and more youtube
videos more resources that we can look
at
but what was it like for you was it
almost like coming in blind like what
was you
what was it like coming to japan back
then compared to
how it is now i mean the first time i
came well i'm sorry the
time i moved here i'd already been here
about six or seven times either doing um
mostly doing work or like what i said
before like i go on holiday
and you know so i had a lot of friends
uh you know make friends with people who
speak english and stuff you know i'd
have flaws to sleep on
and yeah contacts and things like that
which you know with japanese people
they're very friendly like if
you know you can impose on a japanese
person terribly for like two or three
days
and they're kind of happy they don't
mind it's like yeah you're gonna be a
couple of days that's fine yeah right so
i had a pretty good idea of what i was
getting into at that point
and i knew i'd have like i sort of set
myself up with people okay i want to buy
a car
i want somewhere to stay i want i need
all this sort of stuff and i kind of
worked out how to do it
so it wasn't really that bad and i knew
like you know i bought a kick ass laptop
we've got internet um when i first
arrived and i was staying at my friend's
house
uh you know they had internet there i'm
like oh what so what's the is there like
a download limit i don't wanna
i don't wanna like i don't wanna get
throttled and they're like what's a
download live
i love this country every australian
coming to japan yeah
right does australia still have
downloads oh not now i don't know well
probably america
no it does yeah it does too and i
couldn't believe it i was like what do
you mean you only get three gigabytes a
month
yeah that's ridiculous i use like like
20 gigabytes a day minimum
yeah for like youtube and netflix
nowadays how how'd you
do that criminal man it's criminal man i
i wonder like how is
because i i feel like when i've asked uh
japanese people who've been you know who
are like 30 40 plus
you know how japan was back then they're
like oh not much has changed but i think
because they've been living here they
don't see it that way
i wonder like as someone who came here
in 2005 how is japan like different
than from now like majorly is there
anything that's changed like
the biggest thing i mean there's been a
quite a few changes in the past year
honestly
yeah yeah
as from a foreigner's point of view uh
accessibility to everything is just
it's just wide open now yeah you wanna
you wanna know how to get to
random little place google
yeah that's it and there's there's
pictures of what it looks like
it's just so easy like no matter where
you want to go it's it's much easier now
whereas back then
you know like for example going to
akihabara you'd find some random uh
you know guys blog that he'd like he was
like obsessed a bit because the problem
was like back then people
would flavor their content with their
own
tastes yeah yeah this guy was obsessed
with
finding like laserdiscs yeah certain
things
and he like laserdiscs and um porn
i just forgot that only two reasons you
should go
all right i mean one of them's in phased
out the other one hasn't been the other
one has exploded in popularity
the so the uh you know it would tell you
all these places to go
and he had like you know where all the
at like all the anime studios are like
yeah he's gynax
whatever it's like if you want to go
they had a map of where they were it
wasn't there wasn't a map it was just
like
like it was like a literally um
directions from the closest station like
walk to this corner and turn left it was
creepy yeah it was it was weird
but i mean it's it's just how it is yeah
just find things like i've still got the
first notebook of like my first trip
there's a lot of like printed out
maps and handwritten notes and things
like that
how do you navigate a handwritten map of
our cover like it looking through google
maps is already confusing
you just walk down the street and just
hope for the best
well that's well i mean it's it but it's
it's it's so
no matter where your turn is like
there's something yeah yeah and even if
you want to look
i i've sort of found about japan is you
focus on one thing and then see what you
find along the way
because you'd always find these random
like i mean all the best stuff is like
oh this is what's this random floor oh
it's like some dojinshi shop and you
find
oh wow there's all this cool stuff here
like that's yeah so you didn't really
need it back then
was there any foreigners back then like
in japan so there isn't that many now
but i
imagine it was even less back then so
for akihabara the biggest notice the
biggest difference between then and now
is uh there's less video games and more
the claw machines
yeah okay uh the the billboards
are more blatantly
how do i put it like say what it is
although although on the other hand
though the uh like the um the error gear
shops
are not like right out in front anymore
like they're all on the ground
yeah they're like back then like like on
the on the front the front of the edge
shop they have like the big wall with
like each of the games and a little
ticket
yeah so you just you on the street
you're like i want
oh i love this you know something sister
something
you go inside and buy it whereas now
it's more sort of all shut up
yeah yeah it's more like tourist
friendly like they still have like the
maids and stuff also yeah the maid stuff
like that didn't that was
none of that back then oh really was it
not yeah like originally
i mean there were but now it's like
every corner it's like the new made one
and yeah yeah like there's the big ones
but there's not all like the
the little niche ones like like the
ninja one
yeah i think i watched a documentary
yesterday of an akihabara
that was like 2005. it was just horribly
edited
right it was like a horror show i mean
that's that's what every anime
documentary was like back
yeah yeah i i don't even know what it
was supposed to be though like it was i
couldn't figure it out but there were
they had there was like made they were
showing some made cafes around but it
looked like
very early on yeah like i think like the
sketch i think that was
around the time it happened because they
were following the author of higurashi
oh and his family oh wow that was really
weird because
in this documentary for some reason i
know this is going on tangent it just
made me laugh my ass off there because
this super serious documentary
and the guy with higurashi he had his
whole family helping him make it
and then his dad was in charge of
research and his dad
dead ass to the camera goes yes i had to
study how much gas
it would take to blow up a classroom for
one of his novels and i was like
what
how did you find that out like what
resources is there out there like
it's the difference between a large
explosion and a small fire
but did you really have to find out how
much cast there was could you have made
up some arbitrary amount of gas
who's going to read higarashi like fact
check it's like it's like oh i don't
believe that's the right amount of gas
to blow this classroom
yeah i mean come on like modern day
america hadn't happened yet come on
in like how to [ __ ] kill bodies right
how did this weird like i was really
tensioned but that was just about the
documentary 2005.
it was slightly different you know even
even more
of the old uh the old electronic stuff
was still
this still is now but it would that was
i thought that was cool like that was
the main stuff though right yeah like
you turned down some random alley and
it's all like
blade runner electronics and stuff yeah
it's really cool because
my dad like when he first came to japan
it was like in the
like the mid 90s like like kind of early
to mid 90s like before i was born
um and like back then akihabara was
called electric city yeah yeah
nowadays it's there's barely any of that
[ __ ] anymore right like the electronics
shops and everything are like all behind
like in alleyways or
yeah there's like the big anime shops
that you actually go in the first
level yeah yeah that's where all the
electronic stuff is right yeah
because like you go you go out you go
out the uh train and you see like the
electric town exit
yeah the electric tower i remember my
first time coming i was like why is that
why is it called electric town
exit well what has this got to do with
electricity
as eventually that's eventually going to
be just be like the anime town